[Music]
up next is valerie in san antonio hey
valerie welcome to the ramsey show
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um i just needed some i guess financial
advice um
real quick synopsis um widowed in 15.
i remarried last year
i have four
children remaining in the household that
are mine
from the previous marriage
husband had no children we just had a
newborn
about six weeks ago
we're trying to still figure out how
to
merge assets together um i had over 700
000
of more equity assets she had
liquid
i guess like um
cash flow
for lots of better work because i don't
work
um about 150 of retirement
and we still can't figure out i think a
lot of the arguments is a lot of
financial aspects because it's kind of
penny pinching each other because we
don't want to join them together we
don't want to you know i don't want it
to be unfair for him with four
additional children and he doesn't want
to be impaired for me you know feel like
she's you know feeding off of us um
i paid uh i bought a house in cash 555
um i took a small
mortgage on it all right how old are you
how old are you
i'm i'm 38. how old is he
he's 38. what's his income
his income is about 87.
okay
all right
he knew you had four
he knew you had four children when he
married you right
well i actually have seven yes before
they're living with me yes he knew you
had four children that he was going to
be helping to raise
the rest of the way
they come with the package didn't he
yes and you knew he didn't have 700 000
in equity but had a good income didn't
you
i did this is what you both signed up
for
combine it and shut up
okay you want the marriage to be you
want the marriage to be right or you
want to keep your stuff
i wanted to be right yeah that's what i
think
and that's why i'm being so harsh with
you okay
because here's the thing you guys are
you know if you want to back up and do
some kind of pre-nup but i think it'd be
ridiculous on or posting up or whatever
you call those things i think it'd be
ridiculous on this amount of money i i
think that you love him he's committing
his
the next decade of his life to finish
raising your last four and pouring a lot
of his income into it while you stay at
home you're committing your equity to
this situation uh and the two of you
love each other and you're going to
spend the rest of your lives together
you're only 38 when you're 88 and it's
been 50 years and you look back
all of this should have been melded
together shouldn't it
yeah
i think so it's the only way it's going
to work
and so if if he thinks he's some kind of
cool dude because he brings an income or
you think you're some kind of cool chick
because you got some equity
then you two are going to be at each
other the rest of your lives
okay am i wrong
i i hope you're not because
i it's not working the way we're doing
now because something has to change yeah
i agree
so here's what here's what i'm
perceiving from the outside and and i'm
being kind of smart alec with you and
tough on you but what i'm perceiving
from the outside is
that you guys need to flip what it is
that you think is most important
my observation of people who have high
quality marriages and build wealth over
all these years over these tens of
thousands of people i've worked with is
that they put their relationship ahead
of their money
and you guys are putting your money
ahead of your relationship
makes sense okay
is that fair
is that yeah i think it is yeah it is
it's just a lot of influence
it could go bad it could go bad
but guess what if it goes bad four years
from now the judge is going to give you
all your equity back
because you owned it prior to the
marriage
you're in texas
okay he's not he's not gonna give half
of your stuff after four years of
marriage to your to your husband okay
he's just not gonna do it now after 30
years of marriage yeah probably
but if it goes bad soon
the law accounts for
your concerns
i'm not a lawyer but sadly i've
been in
well had the opportunity to walk through
a lot of these situations with folks who
are going through divorce so
um but but you have to decide what it is
you value more
let's concentrate on that and that means
the other is going to take back seat
and so you guys are trying to say all
right the money's the most important
thing and how do i do that and still
have a quality relationship very
difficult
yeah that's so well said i think it's a
mindset shift for sure it's it's going
from
this is his money this is my money too
it is our money and we're doing this
together
now we always tell young couples and you
guys aren't uh you're not baby children
i mean you're not 21 or something but
um
we always tell young couples you have to
be french once you're married we we we
we we own stuff our stuff you don't have
my stuff your stuff our stuff
and um
you know my wife has not earned an
income outside of the home in over 30
years
but we have a wonderful income
because we're french we we right i mean
that's a big deal yeah and so
um you know and you know and we have to
be real careful because sometimes she'll
go well you know
you're making all this money no no no no
no no we are making all this money i
happen to be the one down there at the
office but we are making all this money
it is our money there's a we here and
you have to really work on that and work
on your pronouns because out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
the bible says
so uh we tell folks to come to work here
don't talk about they or you guys you're
a we once you're here and when you don't
want to be a we anymore go work
somewhere else because we is we
and same thing working here you change
your pronouns when you're a ramsay on
the ramsey team you're we this is we
don't do it that way we
we believe this we
and we'll argue with each other because
we argue about what we think you know
inside this building and you do that in
your marriage too if you're smart so um
it's a good question valerie and your
you know your your how you got here is
reasonable
but as you said what you're doing is not
working
and you may want to do this under the
guidance of a good marriage counselor or
a good pastor walking you through it's
not like you're about to get divorced
but there is a rough patch here and
having somebody help you put language to
it might be really really really
valuable